these three teams are going to be racing
across earth in
minecraft are you guys ready yeah then
go
oh sprint boys currently me and the boys
are in california and the first team to
get all the way from california to china
wins we need to gather resources we need
to get a bunch of wood
to the trees start shopping start
shopping i'm going to make you guys axes
right now
perfect you guys are doing great team
purple is winning
get the kelp get the kelp speed is key
speed and momentum what's our strat
okay we're going that direction behind
you all right that way oh yeah that [ __ ]
what's up purple team how's everything
going we're already like halfway there
it's insane
you're nowhere near halfway there let's
go come on oh it's so hard to steer
they look like a little gang of pirates
chandler has a circle around him and his
team has to stay within the circle or
they take damage like this guy
although he's taking damage everyone
stay tight stay tight you guys are way
behind chandler chandler left like five
minutes ago
we have a plan there's no mobs in the
water baby
all right this is weird team carl is
still in the spawn they are still
gathering resources
together we're marching skellington
we're gonna go all right let's go look
at these dolphins this is so beautiful
this is like a movie so chris what what
is your plan we'll avoid all the damage
by going through the water we're gonna
go around the gulf of mexico we're gonna
be coming across panama is this what it
was like when they discovered america
they were in robots hugging each other i
have seven shields
seven shields guys you should probably
start moving now i know this
is all you guys i'm just along for the
rides
there's multiple teams behind us on the
map green and yellow team are behind us
is that all the teams yeah
there's only two other teams oh we're
ahead then we're in first just follow
the purple block
zombie all right we are doing
great i have the map pulled up here and
as you can see chandler's team is
currently heading south it literally
looks like they're preparing for war you
guys are making the journey across
america how's it going carl
i think it's going well i think there
might be people that are ahead of us but
they're not going to be ahead of us
because
we're we're playing it smart guys i'm
looking at the map yellow team looks
like they're like
they're really far behind they're like
just the border of california and mexico
right now
oh someone died wait when you die you're
gone forever yeah that's why we don't
wanna die
yellow team i hate to break it too but
you're getting decimated here's some
speed potions go
faster yeah go go catch up
what's up purple team how are things
going getting materials and then we're
getting back on the boat you guys are
the closest by far but chris
is catching up now you guys are taking a
break and we're off let's get it
go all right and purple team is off
godspeed purple team come on baby what
up green team
what's up man you guys are right on the
heels of purple team what did chandler's
team say
imagine not being first are you guys
just gonna let purple team trash talk
you like this
let's go let's go i'm out of food i out
of food i'm carl
run run
carl's starting to pick up the pace all
right w keys
inbound you hear that you hear that guys
we are ahead
right now green team is just about
arriving where we just landed so they're
they're getting closer
chandler's team they got out of their
boats and crossed on land and then got
back in their boats wait
are they past the panama yes they're
already into the other like side look
epic i'm gonna put pirate music starting
now
you're on your way to conquer europe
do you see uh that one green person
that's really far ahead of everyone wait
how do i get the map
carl before we started i sent you a link
to the map oh nice one carl you didn't
really want the money anyway
chris's team still hasn't crossed the
panama what are they doing they're in
south america right now what are they
doing yo this dolphin is a good luck
charm this is why we're gonna win
start passing out food start passing out
food guys so carl do you have the map of
it now now i do so what are your
thoughts now that you have the map i
sent you an hour ago
open hey listen we're not out of this
we're winners
hey we're in tennessee hey hey team
you're the only ten i see
oh my god it's the rogue green person
the rogue green person god what are you
doing you attacking them i'm getting
their boats
so thought's going on a suicide mission
to mess up their boats break his boat
work his boat oh my god what's going on
oh oh he's wrecking the boats go go go
go go
yeah wait the rest of the green team is
starting to pass us guys so we are
currently passing chandler's team we're
beating carl too
let's go we're back in the lead baby
tennessee slowed him down
turn the trees on your way guys we're
setting a statement oh
oh my gosh he's destroying everything
pvp will now do damage
whoa pvp does damage
pd2 does damage kill him kill him kill
him kill him kill him no he's going he's
leading us to our team
stop all three teams are getting pretty
close to finishing crossing the atlantic
ocean yellow team you're almost done
crossing the atlantic what's going
through your minds we're winners
thank god we're gonna see africa like
any minute now carl what country are you
guys landing on in europe we're trying
to go to the spain area
how many players do you think you'll
have left on your team yeah nobody's
inside the circle
i'd say we're all gonna survive let's go
all right purple team welcome to africa
well
let's go what drives you to go through
such links to screw purple over
a loser's life is not our winner's life
honestly that almost made me shed a tear
wait who is that the lone guy that's
that the road go kill him we'll kill him
oh they're coming
they're coming for you thought no i'm
dead i died
what happened oh that was slay no
we remember your service oh salute
all right go go go go get out of the
boats get out of boats boats aren't
useful anymore
well i think we're in last place now
this is this is brutal everyone give
chandler the food then chandler's
split between like three people and we
just gotta leave everyone else behind
like that's the only way i can think of
winning what's going through your mind i
just watched him get murdered
he delayed chandler and that's what's
got us in the lead thought was a big
part of this
operation yellow team welcome to space
let's go to madrid
olaf this will get us by for right now
you're a legend
yeah they're catching up we gotta go
swim up the coast whenever the players
die they tp to antarctica but if you
zoom out you'll see that somehow
thought escaped from the prison it is
still trying to sabotage chandler why
are you swimming instead of being in
boats
because we can't be in boats anymore
because i disabled boats
because this isn't a swimming challenge
swimming doesn't use hunger
our brains are so big they're throbby oh
no titanic type beat over here guys be
aware
oh you said you weren't gonna leave
people behind what is this what do you
mean
rival of the fittest is all it is bro
we're killing it oh my god we're making
grounds oh my god
remember thought the guy that died
brother our fallen comrade he broke out
of our prison camp in antarctica and
he's
dead sprinting on a trajectory to meet
chandler's team in india yes
yes guys we're actually almost in first
like we're almost tied for first right
now
so purple team how are things going mr
beast we are starving to death we have
no food
we had to sacrifice teammates to
consolidate the food i guess that was
one of the downsides of going through
africa because there's no food yeah i'd
say so
don't take fall damage don't forget that
is very imperative oh look at all these
pigs to the right
oh no oh people are starting to die that
was yellow team as well
i think we're in syria right now i think
we're about halfway through the desert
guys
and then um we go back to water and i
think we're on water franchise of the
way keep pushing
god there's so many mountains carl's
team is pretty much
right in line with us right now oh my
god we're in the lead we're in the lead
we're in the lead we're in the lead
yeah we're doing it we had some ups and
downs but we're doing this see yellow's
ahead of us
but we're gonna have water and they're
gonna have to slow down a lot more
go swimming let's go oh i have to pee so
bad
hold on i've had like four cups of
cranberry juice
yeah get that kelp boys like keeping us
alive
real barack obama you are literally in
the middle
of the desert in africa all alone what's
going on
well i got disconnected and then i got
lost and now here
as you can see carl's team is all spread
out all over italy chris's team right
here is mostly consolidated
i don't know what's going on with
chandler's team it's anyone's game i
have no idea who's gonna win carl i'm
holding up a number between one and two
if you pick the number i'll give you
guys speed boost
if you pick the wrong number i'm gonna
give you guys slowness two
are you sure it's two yeah two yes
that's what i'm holding you guys get a
speed boost
yes go go go we don't stop i'm holding
up a number between one and two
on my fingers uh one i'm sorry but i
gotta give you guys slowness
i literally can't even move no dude
team what number should i pick one
because we're number one yeah
exactly one i don't know who said one
because we're number one but they led
you a straight slowness
oh i was gonna say two we gotta go we
gotta make up this ground
they're falling behind slow down we're
already as slow as we can go we can't
get any slower purple team you are
currently in first place probably
because you have a smaller squad let's
go
i kind of like where your heads at just
screw half the team they don't matter
it's for the team i still don't even
know what we're winning like i don't
know if i'm gonna win like a bounce
house or like 50 cents like i have no
clue we're like directly above
india guys i really gotta pee i super
gotta pee i understand how carl got so
ahead oh my god we're actually gonna win
i'm not gonna lie i had zero faith guys
yes we're in a good biome now we're
sprinting now boys
anyone else is like finger hurting from
holding on w so long
no pain no gain is this about helping
chris's team or is this about revenge
it's both this is thought right here
this is yellow team thought you're
closing in
i wanted to go to the bathroom like
three hours ago
guys we're gonna go to the left of these
mountains i think that's just the move
do you see how far ahead carl is
yeah here's the thing we're better thott
decided to put revenge aside and instead
of going after chandler's team in india
he is now on a trajectory to kill carl's
team
do everything you can for us all right
you're getting close
thought thought you're getting close he
literally ran all the way through africa
to stop you guys from antarctica
get him get him all right he's going in
where's our pvp guy where's our pvp guy
going
jordan oh no oh he got somebody yo dog
gotta kill
oh oh all of us have to turn at the same
time three
two two one one go oh you almost got him
you almost got him
oh step oh oh yes yes
i'm gonna get killed by puffer fish i
died on buffer fish once they touch this
they have literally walked across the
entire planet here's the first yellow
team member it's like a staircase it's
perfectly built for us and they're sheep
and water getting water getting water
getting water getting water
go boys be careful be careful carl oh
there's a border there's a border come
on up guys
guys go up through that water all right
the rappelling down favorite valley down
and congratulations we did it
yeah yellow team has officially crossed
the entire world
carl you get a crisp high five next time
i see you yeah
and the other five of you get ten
thousand dollars in itunes or google
play gift cards split amongst you hey
congratulations on winning walking
across the world i love all of you